hey how you doing this is Mel strong and
this lecture is on how to identify and
name clouds now we're not going to talk
about the processes that actually form
the clouds that will be in a future
lecture but here what we're doing is
we're learning a naming system that was
developed by Luke Howard a couple
hundred years ago Luke Howard was a
pharmacist and he just really liked
clouds and he painted paintings of
clouds and then in 1802 he published a
classification system because up to that
point there wasn't one and his
classification system isn't perfect but
it's still in use today and his cloud
names are still in use today so that's
what we're gonna learn and in his system
you need to know two things to name a
cloud you need to know the clouds shape
and you need to know the clouds height
above the ground now as far as shape
goes all clouds in this system have to
fall into one of three possible shapes
cumuliform strata form of C reform and
I'll show you examples of these shapes
in in a minute and then for height we
just have three categories of heights
little middle and high and with those
three shapes and those three Heights we
come up with ten different cloud names
in this system so first we're going to
go through the shapes and cumuliform
shape clouds are also known as heap
clouds these are the clouds if it kind
of puffy looking they might kind of look
like cotton or cauliflower and they
might be wider than they are tall they
might be taller than they are wide they
might be just a little tiny puff balls
they may be low droopy clouds but all of
these have something in common which is
they all have this kind of puffy edge on
them right so these are all Kimo form
clouds now the stratiform clouds are a
lot more boring and they're sometimes
called the layered clouds they're like
these big blankets to cover the sky and
so you don't usually see a lot of
features within these clouds maybe you
can see the Sun poking through maybe not
but just think of like a big solid gray
sky and
that's a stratiform cloud usually can't
see the edges of these then
xeroform are the clouds that are kind of
wispy or curly or hairy sometimes
they'll they'll have little hooks on the
end sometimes not here's some that have
little heads with whole feathery trails
leading off of them these are pretty
straight so there's a lot of varieties
in in ceará form clouds now we've talked
about the three shapes let's talk about
the three heights and in order to
understand these this little middle high
terminology we have to explain a little
bit how the atmosphere is structured and
so let's imagine that we've got a
mountain range here and we were let's
say to launch a balloon up into the air
above this mountain range and on the
balloon we put a temperature sensor so
it could tell us what the temperature is
which is what a weather balloon actually
does and so if we had a balloon and we
let it launch and we collected all this
data as it climbs up into the atmosphere
and then we took all that data let's
just say it's collecting temperature
data and we made a plot right and in my
plot I've got an x-axis of temperature
so it's warmer to the right colder to
the left and I plot height on the y-axis
and I were to plot that data that that
balloon measured my graph would look
kind of like this at first the balloon
would notice its warmest near the
surface and as it goes up into the
atmosphere cools and cools with height
and that probably makes sense to you
because if you go up to the top of a
mountain it's usually colder up there
we'll learn in a later lecture that when
the sunlight passes through the
atmosphere it really doesn't interact
with it it warms the ground and the
ground warms the atmosphere from the
bottom but for now all we have to
realize is that this this trend happens
and then at some point something weird
happens the our little weather balloon
would notice that the air actually
starts warming up as it gets when it
gets to a certain point and continues to
warm up as you go higher okay now in a
later lecture we'll explain more about
why this happens but for now all we're
going to say is that
this little inflection point between
where the atmosphere cools with height
and when it starts to warm with height
that that forms a natural boundary
between two layers in the atmosphere and
all the air below that line is called
the troposphere and all air above that
line is called the stratosphere so the
reason we're talking about this is this
little middle/high business that refers
to low middle high in this layer in the
bottom layer of the atmosphere now the
exact height of this varies by season
they can vary by day if it's a really
cold day it will be lower if it's a hot
day it'll be higher if you're in the
tropics it's higher if you're near that
pulls it slower but kind of worldwide
average is close to seven miles above
the ground is where this division is so
our low middle high clouds have to fall
somewhere between close to the ground
level and up to as high as maybe seven
miles
so roughly we just divide that like this
low clouds middle calls high clouds now
there's a problem with this and that we
don't have a word for a cloud that's in
here or a cloud that's in here so we
kind of have to force clouds to fall
into one of these three categories so
like I said it's not it's not
necessarily a perfect system so the high
and mid clouds have a prefix so if a
cloud is up here we give it a prefix 0
and if a cloud is kind of around here we
give it a prefix Alto if the cloud is
down here it does not have a prefix this
will make more sense when I give you
some examples ok so let's start with one
I have a quinoa form cloud and it's low
I call it cumulus all right now I take
that puffy cloud and I move it up to
kind of the middle of the troposphere I
would call that Alto cumulus either
looks smaller and I'll show you pictures
of these in a second but that also tells
you the mid level of the atmosphere or
the troposphere if I move that puffy
cloud up higher you know again peer up
here even smaller and it'll have that
prefix 0
you can do the same thing with Stratus
cones it works a little bit differently
so here's a high Stratus cloud a blanket
that would be cirrostratus with also
Stratus usually what that means is that
that high cloud extends all the way down
to the middle of the atmosphere at
middle of the troposphere that's
altostratus and if it extends down
almost to the ground doesn't have to
touch it but gets low we'll call that
Stratus so again there's no prefix here
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna go
through some pictures of some of these
clouds and we're gonna learn
the cloud names that we're going to
learn how to identify them so first
we're gonna start with chemo and chemo s
are probably the most commonly known
cloud these are the clouds that you see
on a summer day a lot of times here in
New Mexico and if you watch this for a
while you'll see the clouds will grow
and they'll die and they kind of drift
around but they're not getting too
terribly large now these are considered
low clouds and this is one of the things
you kind of have to get used to is
recognizing what we call a little cloud
and what we call middle cloud and the
high cloud so everything I'm showing you
here are low clouds if you ever lay in
your back and you're looking up at
shapes changing in the clouds you're
probably looking at cumulus clouds
sometimes especially here in New Mexico
in the summer they'll have flat bottoms
that's not always the case but that's a
common feature that they have so
depending on when you look they may have
different proportions so right here that
one's wider than it is tall but as I sit
here and watch this grow now it's the
same height as it is wide and then as I
wait I can see now it's getting taller
than it is wide and later in a later
lecture we will talk all about though
what's happening here and like why this
is why this cloud is growing but the
point is the proportions can be totally
different just depending on when you're
looking so you know this cloud is
clearly getting pretty tall
it started out you know lighter than it
was tall but it's changing that as the
day progresses so here's some for
example that just about as tall as they
are wide notice that these are also have
mostly flat bottoms here
here's one that's taller than it is wide
so here's a typical summer day in New
Mexico we've got a bunch of little
cumulus clouds here and if you watch
them for a while you'll see one being
born and then you watch it and pretty
soon it will die and dissipate and they
just continue to be born live for a
while and die as the day continues so
these are all cumulus most importantly
when the opening credits of The Simpsons
occurs the clouds that they show are
cumulus clouds and in fact in the city
where they live
cumulus clouds are the only cause they
ever have that show so now let's move up
to Alto cumulus clouds so now these are
going to be higher above the ground so
naturally they're going to appear
smaller because they're farther away
from us but the clouds themselves are
actually also smaller and here's some
typical Alto cumulus so these are
considered mid cloud so and so now these
are not low and these are considerably
further up in the atmosphere you can see
how they're smaller and often they will
kind of form a patchwork pattern cumulus
clouds are more kind of randomly spaced
altocumulus often form these patterns
kind of like what we're seeing here like
a patchwork again sometimes they'll be
touching each other sometimes they won't
be touching each other another example
so everything we're seeing here is a
mid-level cloud and so nothing here is
considered low levels again this is what
takes some practice to get used to here
they're all touching and these clouds
are a little bit lower than the previous
slides but these are still considered
altocumulus clouds and here you can't
even see the sky so that's that is a
possibility that they could form a
continuous blanket of cloud okay so
that's altocumulus they don't
necessarily have to be independent
little puff balls a lot of times they'll
align themselves in rows and we call
this Anjali artists but all you need to
know here is that these
actually aligned rows of altocumulus
clouds so still puffy clouds still
mid-level in the troposphere alright
let's go on to cirrocumulus and because
they're so high up these are little tiny
puffy clouds that you can actually kind
of see through right like white was
shining through cirrocumulus clouds
because they're so thin and you know
they're tiny because they're far away
but they're also literally very thin
clouds and zero cumulus clouds often
form patterns in a similar way that the
altocumulus form patterns so sometimes
they'll be this patchwork a lot of times
they'll often also form in these rows
kind of like this and this so again
that's that undulated texture that with
that die I alluded to earlier so these
are again upper part of the atmosphere
so here's something rose you can see
they're a little bit okay so
cirrocumulus now this brings up an issue
which is how can you tell the difference
between cirrocumulus and altocumulus
because they're both puffy and they're
both kind of small and though these
super tiny little dots right so if you
saw super tiny little dots you're pretty
easily in cirrocumulus but if you have
bigger ones how can you tell them apart
they might kind of be the same size and
so one way to think about this is think
about it like you're a painter and
you're gonna paint these two images of
clouds so notice the one on the left
this is our altocumulus it has more
shading it's more 3-dimensional the
cirrocumulus is more 2-dimensional and
appearance they're so high up there that
you can hardly see any shading now this
doesn't work 100% of the time especially
if it's sunrise sunset and you have a
low Sun angle a lot of times you'll get
shading even on cirrocumulus but if
you're one of my students and you're you
have to identify which one of these
clouds you have go with the shading if
you see shading you
no it's altocumulus if I give you one
that does not have shading and just
looks two-dimensional go with
cirrocumulus so there's a fourth puffy
cloud that actually does not exist at
just one of these three levels but in
fact can exist at all of those three
levels at the same time it starts out
low and it grows up high and that's
called the cumulonimbus now a
cumulonimbus also has another more
popular name which is thunderstorm
because this Nimbus means precipitation
so anytime you have a puffy cloud that
is precipitating whether it be rain or
snow you go with cumulant Nimbus even if
it's not making any audible thunder or
you can see any visible lightning just
the fact that you have precipitation out
of the cumuliform cloud we're going with
Kindle and Nimbus so here's an example
of what is first a cumulus cloud right
now but then notice right there we're
starting to get some precipitation and
in the later lecture we'll explain why
this is happening but for now just
realize that achelous can sometimes turn
into a cumulant cumulonimbus if the
conditions are right so once you see
precipitation you have to go with a
cumulonimbus now here's a classic
cumulonimbus
and you can see that at the top of this
you are getting kind of there's a kind
of fuzzy appearance on the top of this
cloud and that's called the anvil and
the anvil is made of ice and in fact
you'll notice that this part of the
cloud has a very sharp boundary between
the puffy part and in the air and this
part is very fuzzy this is how you can
tell the difference between ice and
liquids so you can have clouds that are
have little microscopic liquid droplets
and you can have clouds that have a
little microscopic particles of ice and
the difference is that the ice will look
fuzzy and the boundary of a liquid cloud
will be very sharp and distinct so here
we've got one forming over the Sandia's
that's the anvil and that's all ice now
we can't really see here whether it's
raining down there but if you see the
anvil you're pretty much guaranteed that
it's raining or
or perhaps even snowing so when you see
the anvil think cumulonimbus because
there's no other cloud that forms that
kind of structure so here's some anvils
forming in the distance so what this is
so far away we can't tell if there's
rain or not but when I see that that in
and that animal is growing there and
this is this one's starting to form one
and it will grow these cumulonimbus
start out without an anvil but as time
goes on the anvil will grow and as the
storm becomes more mature but if you
walk out in the distance and you see
that anvil you know they're having a
thunderstorm and then you know this
precipitation so anvils are always going
to be cumulonimbus in this class for
sure if you can actually see
precipitation you also know you've got
cumulonimbus so here we've got a
thunderstorm over the Sandia's you can
clearly see the beginning in the end of
where the rain is falling if you can see
definite boundaries with the rain you've
got cumulonimbus so in this example we
can't see the anvil we can't see the top
of the cloud you can see some flashes of
lightning there but normally you
especially like a New Mexico summer
you'll you this is kind of a typical
cumulonimbus you can see the puffy cloud
above you can see a shaft of rain below
you know you've got cumulonimbus but if
you can't see this up here and all you
get to see is this down here if you can
see a boundary where the rain ends
somewhere you've got cumulonimbus okay
so here's a classic example
cumulonimbus over albuquerque that rain
coming down even though I can't see
anything above here I don't know if it's
got an anvil or anything the fact that I
can see that the the beginning and the
end this rain column tells me it's
cumulonimbus now in the winter sometimes
we can get cumulonimbus and because it's
so cold the entire cloud is made of ice
crystals and you can see that it's fuzzy
up here but it's even fuzzy down there
and this is a cumulonimbus that's
snowing okay so if you see that it still
has this anvil shape
it's snowing all the way down to the
ground there's another type of puffy
cloud that's kind of a special case it's
called stratocumulus so if I have one
low puffy cloud I've got cumulus if I
have two low puffy clouds I always still
call them cumulus but if I have so many
puffy clouds that they end up touching
each other
or almost touching each other and maybe
I can see a little light in between I
don't go with stratocumulus
stratocumulus is actually the most
common cloud type on earth but we don't
see it that much on land because
stratocumulus occurs over the ocean and
we get it once in a while here in New
Mexico so here's some some strategy memo
so if I could just pull out one of those
blobs I'd have one single low cumulus
cloud but I have so many of them that
you know I can see some light in between
and maybe I'll get a glimpse of the sky
or maybe not I'm gonna call this
stratocumulus so classic stratocumulus
they look very you know they're very low
they look very heavy very bulbous on the
bottom usually typically worldwide you
don't see so much flat bottoms on the
strategy models like you do on on your
cumulus clouds kind of they over time
they just kind of have those they roll
and very slowly changes their shapes but
again you can see the breaks in between
can't really see the sky here so that's
strata cumulus I took this from a plane
looking down this is what strategy most
looks like from above and if you were to
fly over the oceans sometimes you will
see this for just thousands of miles and
in this is just like I said this is the
most common cloud type on earth the
stratocumulus it tends to form over the
oceans now it might be confused with
this one this is when we just saw this
is the altocumulus and the altocumulus
kind of looks like the strategy Mullis
but these are higher up in the
atmosphere and the stratocumulus are low
only so keep in mind this is a mid cloud
whereas this is a low-cost so you can
see it brush in the top of the Sandia's
there kind of in the in the distance
there so that's kind of how you can tell
these two things apart is it if it's low
in there it's just solid puffy clouds
stratocumulus
if it's mid-level altocumulus so we've
gone through all the cumuliform clouds
and now we're going to go through the
stratiform clouds which are a lot less
interesting to look at we're going to
start with Stratus which is a low
stratiform cloud and the key to
identifying Stratus is that you cannot
tell where the Sun is so it's a gray sky
and in this time-lapse the Sun is
actually right there but you can't see
it so if you've got a gray sky and you
can't point to the Sun then you've got
Stratus okay so might be light gray
might be dark gray there might be some
texture in the sky there might not be
but what's consistent is that you can't
tell where the Sun is now if that gray
sky is also producing precipitation
either rain or snow we're going to call
it nimbostratus there's only two types
of clouds that produce precipitation
cumulonimbus which is the puffy one in
nimbostratus Stratus which is the
layered one and nimbostratus you know
grey sky as far as the eye can see
producing precipitation as far as the
eye can see
right so with cumulonimbus you could
tell that or the boundaries of the
precipitation were or at least one of
the boundaries with nimbostratus you
can't tell where the storm ends because
it just from your perspective looks like
it's going on forever in all directions
okay and again it can be rain or can be
snow that's pneumo Stratus okay now if
our cloud deck is thinner and we get up
to the middle part of the atmosphere we
call that altostratus
and because it's thinner cloud the Sun
will kind of poke through except it will
be a fuzzy ball so here is some
altostratus and you can see we can point
to where the Sun is but it's a fuzzy
ball right so that's your key for Altos
Stratus
gray sky but you can identify where the
Sun is in each case all right so
altostratus so when we get to the top of
the troposphere we have a very thin
layer of cloud that we call cirrostratus
and not only is this cloud very thin but
because it's so high up it's actually
very cold and it's entirely made of ice
crystals and it turns out that when
light shines through a layer of ice
crystals it makes an optical pattern it
makes a circle and cirrostratus clouds
are characterized by this ring that goes
around the Sun now the pictures I'm
showing you here are not mine I have a
really hard time getting good pictures
of cirrostratus clouds and some of these
I've been able to track down the source
some of these are just there all over
the internet and I can't figure out
where they originated from so I can't
give everybody credit but key is that in
a cirrostratus cloud you might see the
Sun as a fuzzy ball but the key is look
for this ring and that ring will
sometimes have little rainbow colors in
it so for this is probably the best one
I have we can kind of see some color in
there not only do you get a ring around
the Sun but you can get a ring around
the moon and this guy shows you how thin
this cloud is like you can see stars
through it right so it it's even harder
to call it a cloud but we do it's just
this very thin layer of ice crystals
away at the top of the tropopause
okay so cirrostratus you're looking for
the ring okay so we've gone through
cumuliform
we've gone through stratiform now we're
to see reform and with sea reform clouds
there's actually only one type there are
no low clouds there are no middle clouds
or only high cloud versions of sea
reform and so those are called Cirrus
and because they're so high up in the
sky they are entirely ice and they have
kind of there's a wide variety of
textures for cirrus clouds typically
they're very you know kind of wispy
hairy feathery looking so these kind of
look
cobwebs sometimes they cross each other
they look like they're kind of tangled
up like these here are some that look
more feathery and these kind of have a
net-like appearance sometimes they'll
get so dense that it will appear solid
gray and some people might try to call
this cirrostratus but if you're one of
my students if you can see the edge
something like this still go with with
Cirrus a lot of times they'll be hooked
so you see some of these have little
hooks on them and occasionally they'll
be just perfectly straight so here are
some perfectly linear cirrus clouds here
are some of those hooks here are some
that have this generating head with a
little tail on it okay here's something
that crisscross each other so there's
there's all kinds of shapes of cirrus
clouds but they're pretty easy to
identify they don't look like anything
else that we've seen here so those are
the ten cloud types as originally
outlined by Luke Howard back in 1802 and
most of the clouds you will ever see
will fit in one of those categories but
there are a few odd balls that don't
completely fit and I'm gonna give you
two more and these two you actually will
see in New Mexico occasionally so for
the first one here we've got the
Sandia's and there is wind that's
blowing up over the Sandia's and for
reasons that will explain in a later
lecture when air rises it it can form
clouds so there's this little cap of a
cloud that sits on the mountain okay now
that cap is now grown and it's starting
to get this shape that's kind of a
disc-shaped and we call these clouds
lenticular clouds or if i zoom out a
little bit more okay so this whole thing
now is this air mass moving over the
mountain is creating this this disc
called the lenticular cloud but
sometimes the air when it moves over the
mountain the cloud isn't actually
touching the mountain
so for example here we've got air moving
over the mountain and it's creating
lenticular clouds that are hovering
above the mountain but it's is still the
same process here are some more okay so
these are all lenticular clouds these
disc shapes and there's air moving over
the mountain here sometimes they occur
in stacks so these are low clouds those
are cumulus down there lenticular can be
usually there low to mid clouds these
are you know fairly low but they're
higher than the cumulus in this one and
often you will see chains of lenticular
clouds so you so sometimes they'll get
isolated little disks and sometimes you
get a whole bunch of them coming all
together and you can see in this how
there's air moving in and out of these
lenticular clouds so there's a big kind
of wave here in the atmosphere that's
causing this and the wave is very slowly
moving from left to right in this
time-lapse here's something similar so
we've got a we've got a wave in the
atmosphere and these lenticular clouds
are writing the top of that wave and the
wave is very slowly moving from left to
right so one thing that can happen with
lenticular clouds is let's say we've got
a mountain range and we've got wind
coming out of the in this case let's say
this is the Sandia's and and when we'd
be coming out of the west and air is
going to be forced up the mountain now
we'll learn in a later lecture that if
you take air and you push it up
eventually it will reach its dew point
in form of cloud and so that's going to
happen here and we're going to get this
little lenticular cloud that forms on
the top of the mountain
okay now the air goes down the other
side of the mountain but the thing is
air is compressible and it's bouncy su
v--'s if you compress air it kind of
bounces back so what happens is as the
air comes down the mountain it'll
actually bounce in the atmosphere and
you know you can't see this but there
will be these big waves
that form in the atmosphere and at the
top of each wave if the wave goes high
enough it will make another ticular
cloud so often you don't just get one
you often get it a whole chain of
meticulous so that's what's happening
here this is Mount Shasta there's a
lenticular hat kind of on the top and we
also see some lenticular clouds nearby
and that's they're all related that
we're making waves in the atmosphere
from that mountain interacting with the
wind so here a whole chain and one took
your clouds again I've gotten images
here that I can't track down in terms of
the original source but they're very
popular on the Internet so that's what
you're going to see here on some of
these but here's a whole chain of them
so the atmosphere is again kind of
bouncing and as it bounces it makes
lenticular clouds at the top of each of
those waves sometimes it will occur in
stacks okay that's that can happen in
fact here's a image from National
Geographic this is I believe is Mount
Rainier and these are you know big stack
and lenticular clouds on top here's one
I took over campus you don't have to
have a mountain to get lenticular clouds
conditions are right you can get one
tubular clouds just about anywhere but
they the mountains definitely help their
formation would it surprise you if I
told you that every year there are a
alarming number of 911 made because
people we are reporting UFOs when they
see clouds like this maybe that doesn't
shock you but you know that's kind of
convincing right or how about that one I
mean that's the mothership showing up
for sure so some of them really do look
like UFOs and here's another one from
National Geographic and they took this
picture right before the zebra got
abducted here okay so that's when
ticular clouds that's an extra one
another extra one here's a cumulonimbus
so that remember that's the thunderstorm
and sometimes what we'll get right on
the bottom of a
nimbus are these sinking blobs a
cold-air that come down and they form
kind of a droopy looking cloud that's
called the mattes and these will often
happen right before or right after a
thunderstorm occurs so here they are
each one of those blobs is sinking cold
air that's coming down out of this
cumulonimbus here's some more that are
these are better lit here so you can see
them starting to come down we got a
little precipitation over here but for
the most part that's those are just
blobs of cold air here's some good ones
forming right there okay so these are
Alma mattes these blobs coming down so
again sometimes you'll see this right
before a thunderstorm or sometimes
you'll see it right after a thunderstorm
so we do see these in New Mexico in the
summer now here's a there's a
thunderstorm in the distance and this is
the anvil that's kind of drifting over
us and sometimes they'll form in the
anvil itself so you can see some little
blogs in there and sometimes you'll see
really spectacular photos of madness in
New Mexico the best time to see mammatus
is late in the afternoon and when the
Sun angle is low they'll show up better
kind of like this one or this one these
are momentous forming in an anvil so
this whole thing up here is the anvil
and another one again near sunset and it
really exaggerated s-- the the Matis
makes it easier to see a lot of times
the madness that we get here in New
Mexico or not nearly as good as these
pictures I'm showing so this is probably
the best Momentis that I've taken a
picture of here in Albuquerque but this
is kind of more tick typical so this is
on campus and you can see that there's
blobs in there right but it doesn't look
nearly as well-defined as some of those
other pictures okay so in conclusion we
got 10 cloud types that were originally
defined by Luke Howard back in 1802 and
on top of that I'm giving you two others
that don't fit very well in that
original classification system
lenticular and
madness okay so in the next lecture
we're going to start getting into
humidity and we're going to work up to
how these clouds actually form thanks
for watching
you